as hate rang out the US president paused
to let it build after basking in the
chance
he's now distancing himself I was not
happy with it I disagree with it but
again I didn't say I didn't say that
they did his racist attacks on for
non-white Congress women were embraced
with glee by his hard core base across
America who send her back chant has
caused a storm in places like far Kerr
County Virginia where Trump won a
majority it isn't always a negative one
is what Trump is doing racist we all say
things that sometimes we probably don't
want them to come out the way they came
out I don't think he is a racist person
I feel very deliberate though doesn't it
we've gotten very sensitive he can't be
responsible what people chanting focus
on fixing all the other country's
problems but from what I've heard one of
them married a brother to get into this
country which is illegal you can't tell
me it's not true Trump has successfully
built a false narrative around the
Democratic Congress women these ideas
are not universal here like everywhere
else there are passionate divides Paula
Miller knows some of her clients won't
like what she has to say
I think it's reprehensible it's
unpresidential but I think the past two
and a half years have been totally
unpresidential do you think he saw it
coming in that moment what the chance
oh absolutely oh he's totally calculated
he knows exactly what he's doing is this
racist beyond a doubt of course it's
racist fermenting rage was a trademark
of Trump's 2016 campaign but he seems
ready to take the 2020 election to a
dark new level Amanda Walker Sky News
Marshall Virginia